you just flew in from Boston I just came
from your neck of the woods my neck of
the woods Boston Mass he performed its
Symphony Hall it's that's what the best
place to perform if you're in Boston is
Symphony Hall in the world no no it's
fine as Boston goes it's great but how
is how's the tour going because the tour
your tour is interesting you bring
people out of the audience I've seen so
many fantastic clips online you bring
people out of the audience and you find
the comedy and find the performance with
complete strangers that's got to be kind
of scary well as you know when you
perform live that's what you live for
you want you also want to maybe change
somebody's life right so a lot of times
I'll pick somebody who's like 1213 who
is the obvious choice for me and saying
I do it from for good and sometimes I'll
pick an adult which is not always maybe
the best idea Conan but I did pick
somebody right I like that you turned to
me for adults good I wasn't the adult
here sometimes it can go awry yeah so
I'm curious have you had any mishaps
along the way or everything goes oh
goodness and I was at Virginia and with
a symphony there and I was thinking I
could have danced all night which is a
made famous by the great Julie Andrews
and it comes a big part of the song oh
my god
it's so amazing I don't what does that
voice come from your your small this is
crazy Boise comes out of you it's
amazing it always blows me away
thank you I sometimes just dear lord
please let it come out yeah yeah areas
sometimes you know from here here but
anyway she's not a part of the song oh
and I always pick up my dress my gown
and and I just sway with that part and I
had forgot that um the gown that I chose
to wore that night cuz you know on tour
we change it up all the time this gown
was short in the front and long in the
back so the audience was splashed three
times there is some men that looked so
happy they thought they'd come to my
show
[Laughter]
[Applause]
torrefied some people looked happy but
mostly I think the straight men work
[Laughter]
you